and actually i have a new word
and the new word it's like the new
that's hot
is sliving
[Music]
so it's basically sliving equals living
your best life which is
killing it and slaying in one word paris
hilton's been sliving since 1981 and e.t
has been with her more than half her
life
[Music]
we first met the socialite in 2001 she
was a 20 year old with a modeling career
trying to break into acting i'm going on
castings right now
um well my cameo zoolander which is
coming out like the premiere is like two
weeks hey jared
you roll
thanks paris i appreciate that
e.t was there to send paris off on her
simple life journey with nicole richie i
think it'll be a great experience i'll
never get to do this in my life the
concept is so clever and fun
okay it's 2 37 thank you have a great
day thanks [ __ ] have a great day this
is fun how has this whole experience
changed you guys just made us really
close as friends like having an
adventure with my best friend which
seemed to be a regular thing we'd sneak
out from the family's house and go we
went to peter d's party by 2011 sneaking
out was a thing of the past when paris
showed e.t around her own house complete
with a private club this is club paris
huh yes
i mean
who is a club in their house but you
right
it's a lot of fun because it's better
than going out to a club it's private
you can have whatever you want there
and a stripper bowl
oh yeah paris had a pet pig too
hi guys i think they're excited to see
mommy yeah i missed you guys and how did
this relationship come to be well
princess pigalette has known the puppies
since she was a baby she used to
actually be this big so she thinks she's
a dog we're bff
and while it might seem like paris has
it all the hilton hotel heiress isn't
here for family handouts i'm a
workaholic it's what i enjoy to do since
i was a little girl i always knew i
wanted to be independent and
not have to ask for anything
paris's list of accomplishments include
everything from real estate to handbags
perfume and even shoes
i'm like a shoe girl and a dress girl
like i love pretty dresses and cool
shoes she's also trademarked her famous
catchphrases and landed herself the
title of world's highest paid dj earning
up to 1 million dollars per set that's
what's up
of course there's also her music and
i've actually done a new song for my
album called paris for president so it
has a lot of my thoughts on what would
happen if i was president
[Music]
but the title that excites paris the
most
wife e.t was with her through wedding
planning she and carter room got married
in november
now she's looking forward to starting a
family my sister and i talk about it a
lot but it changes your whole life
completely and brings you just so much
joy i just can't wait for that day one
day
[Music]
you